foreign
[Music]
has changed
[Music]
I want the world to never forget money
our name
senior farad in my opinion you're making
the best cars in the world
but with all my Ferraris that is a
problem a clutch I have a solution if
you consider a partnership Ferrari
Lamborghini go back to your tractors
farmer
what are you thinking digging of a car
that doesn't exist yet one that is a
strong and powerful and is Unforgettable
as the ball
I'm going to build it how long will it
take can't be done if it doesn't work
you'll lose everything you want me to be
like everyone else
it's not impossible until we fail it's
in Geneva people be looking at the next
fight
I will find is the first level
that's something new I don't know if
this would work
[Music]
we'll be ready for this one day
another luxury car it's Perfection that
I am after
I don't care about me the only thing
that matters is a great Lamborghini what
do you want me to do
why are we here to make a car to make
the best cars
do I have a responsibility to tell them
what you're doing
[Music]
Lamborghini is too uneducated to
understand what he doesn't know
you buy a Lamborghini when you are
someone
[Music]
what do you see lines on a napkin what
do you see
[Music]